you know absolutely oh nice start
they're going for the the electric
we're going downstairs
okay oh hell sweet if you're gonna go
downstairs again
oh okay just right as we are this is um
very offensive low parry
is he gonna break the final floor we're
downstairs
it's only been 20 seconds
okay now he's breaking the throne that's
nice
yep
oh my god never think
that hot kick i don't even know he had
that
yeah it's literally just up forward four
oh my god look at this what is he doing
bk
three
okay he's
he may not be playing ling but the
mix-ups are still strong
oh boy oh boy no no duck yeah that's he
could have ducked that there
he's back he's gonna get oh i thought
he's gonna run all the way in he's gonna
run a little bit
oh oh oh oh oh i lost my breath two okay
that sounds very unfortunate
oh no oh no oh no no one will hit and no
that should not work
it worked he pressed the button
ladies and gents we are gonna be going
to a final
[Music]
okay oh here we go now this is now this
is a three-way mix-up okay go for the
sharp shooter this time because i'm a
nerd i know that's a one break
okay nice
is that could you break that because it
was um yeah
so in that situation i think with that
oh my god okay i think it went on four
two one where is it there it is there we
go
oh oh no i thought he's going to read
wall splat again
potato what a comeback one needs to be
very careful because you've done that
before i'm going to parry
oh my god no way double rocky is he
going to get a match on the board oh god
is that going to be it this should be it
yes
to alleviate the pressure oh it was a
float
oh it doesn't get the wall though
oh
no rage available for ultra insane
potato as well he's back into the wall
down back four rage available now what's
he gonna do rafe can you reset the
bracket one more he's gonna do it lasers
and lads we have a reset grand finals
here yola can he finish it right now no
break on the shining wizard okay can
this be a comeback for for all shakes
and potato
does have
ladies and gents ray from saudi arabia
is going to be your tekken online
challenge middle east master champion
[Music]
you